[Music]
so what do you guys fear
when you're on an airplane
[ __ ] crashing crashing crashing
nothing getting sucked out the side of
the airplane yeah
actually my my scariest fear is like not
only when we're crashing but if we're in
one of these these modes oh yeah and
then it's literally like right when the
[ __ ] seatbelt sign goes off so i'm
like hell yeah [ __ ] and then i
go like this and i'm [ __ ] flying down
the [ __ ] hallway all right
i die before the plane even crashes oh
yeah oh yikes that's my damn you would
have to fall so uninterrupted for a long
period i'm [ __ ] buying economy dude
i'm [ __ ] like row 50 and
[ __ ] you're falling to your desk if i
was in first class i'd be right here and
just go pink yeah you know first class
you just fall two feet you'll end up at
the cockpit yeah do you ever feel when
you're walking by people in first class
like they're judging you and you're like
[ __ ] you back piece of [ __ ] because
cause because when i'm in first class
i'm judging those people that walk back
yeah that's what i do too when i did it
i was like ah the pheasants and the back
pores in the back
don't use my [ __ ] back what's the
scariest part of crashing or like
statistically is when you land oh
absolutely yeah yeah so when you land
the wheels all okay [ __ ] up and [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] plane gets all you're
just like oh i'm gonna live no and then
they catch us on fire and [ __ ] like that
so so something that i think is another
terrifying thing that i think about when
flying is like what if something
happened and like hadn't had nothing to
do with the plane mechanics or anything
but like bird hits the plane or some
[ __ ] or yeah some some kind of something
hits the plane and rips a [ __ ] hole
in it and then we're [ __ ] the monkey
on the way that's pretty scary yeah
classic that's scary [ __ ] sometimes i
think about that yo i went down this
weird rabbit hole right so there's like
a there's like a channel that has
that makes documentaries about
planes [ __ ] up like a full-on
full-on dock about why this plane
[ __ ] blew up in the sky why this one
[ __ ] crashed whatever right and then
searching pornhub again
and then why like all this stuff was
developed to fix that [ __ ] but there's
this one plane that was going to [ __ ]
australia it was one of those double
decker [ __ ] like yeah big air buses
those jumbo ones right and then they
showed that there was a malfunction in
like this this [ __ ] it was it was
like what do you call it like those
gimbal no like like uh uh turbine
merry-go-round
no it's like a latch at the very top of
the plane it looked like a [ __ ]
sunroof oh it's like oh oh never mind
never mind i thought were you talking
about the turning things but those are
usually antennas for those giant planes
yeah that's yeah but it was like a weird
sunroof on top of a plane right right
this thing
unlatched in the middle of the [ __ ]
like air and then
uh a flight attendant
oh my god no no but when she got stuck
because she was fat ass
thank god i don't really know but she
got stuck there but that pressure
[ __ ] up the inside pressure and made
it into like a bomb and it exploded the
plane whoa yeah
what so because she was fat the plane
exploded but i don't know she was fat it
was just a small hole and she was the
one that got sucked into it and in that
body pressure imagine being [ __ ]
smashed like crazy and then that
pressure yeah you pop it and it also
popped open the plane oh holy [ __ ] yeah
this is why i don't watch videos like
that well i got a hell of a story for
you okay let's do it oh thank you
passengers we're flying on a plane
having no idea that they were flying for
14 hours with a huge hole in the side of
it oh well and they survived they
survived they have no idea it was a one
million case where as they were
departing
the one of the tires
had
um
kicked up some some [ __ ] into the side
of the plane and [ __ ] ripped a hole
in it but it happened it happened on on
the part of the plane that didn't affect
the cabin at all it didn't affect the
flight so it's like on the bottom cargo
or whatever yeah it's like in this
little [ __ ] area got lucky little
[ __ ] area whoa
that's crazy that's huge it's concerning
yeah bro that's like a fat lady could
get sucked right into it do you think
going at like 400 or 500 miles an hour
that hole would cause some crazy damage
or turbulence right what a testament to
engineering of this plane legit bro oh
that's one story i saw though everyone a
lot of people survived it landed but the
whole [ __ ] plane looked like a
convertible where the top was ripped off
oh my god but everyone's surviving so
people are sitting there with no talk
yeah
yeah that's kind of imagine how loud
that is because that top blew up so some
people flew out of it some people did
you say it was a double decker does that
mean a whole second story like it was
yeah it was [ __ ] ripped and do you
think that the boards were on the bottom
the boards were winning the poor's
definitely back of the plane in the
middle of the plane we're good man
[ __ ] we gotta stay in economy guys
dude emergency row mercy rose lit that's
what i'm like yo it's a game changer i'm
rich [ __ ] yeah
that's that's first you get all this
legroom like this unless unless you have
like a backpack that's just a [ __ ] yeah
so i was on a flight and then like we
got the we got first class for some
reason like the the flights were like
copped or whatever so then we got the
front row oh wow richie [ __ ] rich
richie [ __ ] rich it's a business trip
so we got the front row
the front row of first class [ __ ]
sucks because there's nothing to put
your like stuff under so you so there so
you know how like even in the economy
section you can put your like backpack
underneath the like front seat
so i put my backpack on the overhead and
then my backpack has like a water bottle
slot and i have this big heavy like
hydro flask it [ __ ] fell out hit the
little old guy
in the foot like also in first class
i am so sorry and then i just had to sit
with that with the rest for the rest of
the flight and then when we landed my
friend went up to get my backpack oh no
it came out again no way did it hit the
guy again it didn't hit him but it hit
the floor and i was like
[ __ ] i have so much anxiety right now i
just need to get the [ __ ] off this plane
yeah first row of [ __ ] first class
sucks ass
sucks ass first roll first class i love
hearing rich people problems from ryan
one of two times i've flown first class
dude ryan's like we got problems too
actually
but only in the first row is anything
ever like crazy happening you guys while
you guys are flying where you guys
actually question like are we gonna be
okay yeah um it was a it was a winter in
beijing
and it was like [ __ ] crazy like
winter storm [ __ ] going on
and it was the first time when the
the pilot tried to land
and then went back up into the sky and
we had to do a loop and that i was just
like dude you [ __ ] chinese driving
ass [ __ ] you better hit this you
better do this right did they say
anything after the man and then the
turbulence was nuts so like i don't i
don't remember what was like being said
because i just remember saying like why
are we not landing right now like we're
dipping and then the wheels are touching
and [ __ ] now like whatever is like
[ __ ] weird and then we go back up and
then like people were crying the
turbulence was insane people were crying
[ __ ] dude ladies were [ __ ] like
wailing crying [ __ ] things were
shaking and [ __ ]
my friend the whole time is like i'm not
gonna be able to [ __ ] a hooker in
beijing you know that's what he said
he's like he's like quick he's like
check me off i don't want to die
without getting the nut off i was like
damn dude that's crazy
that was the scariest thing yeah yeah
we're coming back from hawaii so we're
actually we're landing in hawaii it was
my first time going
the the [ __ ] pilot is selling us
credit cards yeah
for way too long bro it was like hey man
what are we doing here that's a
nightmare it was like it was like 10
minutes and he kept saying like oh like
he was like explaining the [ __ ] deal
yeah yeah yeah yeah if he had a hawaiian
accent that would have been better but
he even have only action
come on dude we're about to land we hear
a loud bang nice like a really loud bang
and i was like what the [ __ ]
and then the cabin started filling up
with smoke
and the whole time i'm like tripping
like am i [ __ ] am
air force one [ __ ] so then we [ __ ] it
was and then we land and it was the
bumpiest [ __ ] landing i've ever
experienced
and and then the pilot like mid
commercial on this credit card it like
kind of stops like he doesn't finish the
[ __ ] commercial and then just [ __ ]
lands and he goes hey guys uh we have a
little bit of turbulence and we had some
we have some smoke in the cabin so
everyone just sit tight turbulence don't
cause smoke dude and then the [ __ ]
police department is meeting us at the
the landing point they come on the plane
and they're like yeah everything's all
good and then they just let us off they
don't even tell us a [ __ ] thing we
don't even know how was it what was it
do you think the pilots are ever like
yeah so i'm not laying this [ __ ]
plane to get 50 signups
that's an effective strategy daddy needs
a bonus
daddy's getting his bonus and i'm not
leaving until we fight again were there
any cairns or anyone like [ __ ]
tripping out and saying like what the
[ __ ] i think everybody was excited that
we were laying in hawaii
oh
everyone's just like we're in hawaii now
it's the ladder
let's let's go on with our vacation dude
yeah that's the powerhole does it fill
up with smoke where it's like people
were coughing and [ __ ] or it was like no
i wasn't that bad like hazy yeah you see
it come out and you're just like uh
you're you're kind of panicking i'll
trip the [ __ ] out if i saw smoke in the
cabin like that i thought we were gonna
[ __ ] die i was like dude even me
captain cool i'd probably be freaking
out yeah nice man here you guys gonna
[ __ ] captain cool you guys know
captain cool you guys know i'm captain
cool like you guys know that anytime
[ __ ] like that happens i always wish
there's a chris tucker on the plane
the commentary because for me like i'm
not that expressive yeah but i feel it
your eternal life i want someone to say
someone something so someone else can do
difficult yes if you have a chris tucker
just [ __ ] go on hand but what the
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] smell good
i want somebody else to panic yeah yeah
i know what i'm talking about like i
might be panicking but if somebody else
panics more then i realize i'm maybe not
panicking that much and that makes me
feel grounded me that makes me more
anxious then i'm like dude shut the [ __ ]
up this is not gonna do anything right
now you're just yelling at people i'd
rather be mad at that than be worried
about what's going on yeah that's an
interesting thing that's an interesting
way to divert your energy you guys land
and then as soon as the plane don't
collapse
does do do you get pissed when everybody
stands up yes
yes especially the [ __ ] people behind
me to go get their [ __ ] bags where
the [ __ ] do you think you're going i
know like don't don't do that i'll
[ __ ] look and you know the etiquette
like each role is supposed to unload
first right but some dudes just [ __ ]
dark go to the front yeah yeah and it's
like what the [ __ ]
and then people follow and you just like
[ __ ] i'm just gonna step up
right now to be fair when i have to take
a huge [ __ ] a dart oh because then
otherwise i'm going to be like fatty i
like farting and stuff like you should
be like i gotta poop and then everyone
will be like all right cool yeah i need
a chris tucker friend to do that you
know it was definitely i was on a flight
where we landed in chicago in a really
short layover and then the guy in the
back was like hey guys i hate to do this
but i'm trying to catch a flight my mom
is dying right now like she's on the
deathbed i got to go catch this other
[ __ ] flight and i was like
go i'd be like
no
wait your turn
my mom's dying too
everyone's mom's dying technically
you